so as this is the first video of 2020 I
want to start by wishing everybody a
Happy New Year last year just before the
end of the year and in November in the
beginning of December I went on this
strange binge of creating different
products people had complained that my
that the the t-shirts and products and I
put were a bad quality and so I don't
know I just went on this I just didn't
fell in this zone of creating different
images to kind of put out there and one
of the images that I put out was a
drawing of Alexander the Great and he's
sitting in a chariot and he's being
carried by two Griffin's up into the sky
he's holding these two sticks and at the
end of the sticks are bait and as the
Griffins tried to eat the bait that's
above them they kind of go up into the
sky carrying alexander with them and you
know quite a few people liked the image
but wondered what does this have to do
with anything what is it have to do with
symbolism and so I thought that as we
begin the new year I would take this
time to explore this story I've been
wanting to talk about Alexander for
quite a while I've mentioned him in
passing how his legends are extremely
important in the story in storytelling
because his legend spanned from Mongolia
through all of Islam and Christianity
and Judaism in India there are versions
of his stories and so in when you look
at those stories you can really get this
traditional pattern of storytelling that
kind of crosses the different cultures
and so I guess this will be an
opportunity to look at one of these
stories this ascent of Alexander into
the sky
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so quickly after the death of Alexander
the Great there started to accumulate
around him a bunch of legends and it
happened almost right away even you know
right at his right after his funeral
already these stories started to
circulate about Alexander the Great and
the modern modern historical approach
and the modern historian will want to
try to dismiss these legends that's
possibly one of the reasons why they
seem to have been forgotten in the West
and in modern culture but me the
question that I want to ask is what is
it about a figure that makes legends
accumulate around them what is it about
a character that does that and when
those legends accumulate around these
figures these legends really do tend to
take on this this pattern of
storytelling they really do tend to take
on very archetypal language and very
archetypal structures and so the legend
of Alexander the Great particularly has
this in the Middle Ages it was
recognized as it was called the the
romance of all chivalry that is almost
like as if Alexander's romance which
proceeds even Christianity is the basis
for the chivalric code and chivalric
thinking and the chivalric attitude and
I think there is much to say about that
how there is this relationship with the
way that Alexander conducted himself and
and his campaigns with how Knights saw
themselves and especially as Alexander's
legends took shape in different cultures
they also came to be modified to fit
into those different cultures and so the
Christian Alexander is very particular
and can help us understand also the
manner in which not only what the
ancient world can look like in the eyes
of Christianity but also how stories can
be flipped and be changed in order to
serve another purpose
while you know having the same pattern
than even in a certain extent maybe
refining those patterns to to make them
fit more even better than what they did
before and so the story of the ascent of
Alexander the Great
is based on older old very very old
stories there are stories even in the
time of Gilgamesh and in that these
ancient Babylonian stories of a figure
that gathers for Eagles or for birds or
for creatures and uses those four
creatures to ascend up into the sky and
see the world in the version of
Alexander like I said he builds this
chariot or this throne and he assembles
these four Griffins to carry him up into
the sky and when he goes up into the sky
he sees the different heavens and he
sees all of this and when he looks back
down upon the earth he sees the earth as
this island and he sees the ocean as
this coiled snake around the ocean so
already you can start to understand what
this could mean for us which is that
Alexander was able to rise up above
phenomena and was able to perceive the
pattern of the world was able to get to
a state where he was capable of seeing
the structure of the world that we can
understand it of course in a very common
way you know almost like a scientist
would do it but we could also understand
it more symbolically especially
considering that he saw this snake
around the world and he saw these
patterns of the heavens from close up
now what is what is dangerous about the
story is that on the one hand the story
could seem like a tale of hubris that is
here is you know like Nimrod built this
Tower of Babel like the modern scientist
thinks that they can figure everything
out Alexander also you know takes the
meat takes this flesh puts it up and
uses these monsters to kind of raise him
up into the the sky to be able to master
the entire world and so what's
interesting in the story is that in the
Christian version and I think probably
in the the Muslim and and Jewish version
though I'm not I haven't read them so
I'm not sure something happens as he
ascends and so he ascends to a certain
level and then as he reaches you know
has he's approaching the highest heavens
he hears a voice which tells him that he
has
has to stop there that he can't ascend
any higher and that he now has to come
back down to the world and so by having
that little change in the story what it
does is it also on the one hand creates
that tells you the story of how we do
have access to the patterns of reality
we do by our own reason by our own mind
by our own god-given capacities we have
the capacity to raise up and to see the
patterns of the world but we also have
to be careful because there is a limit
that we cannot go beyond that we cannot
by that means by this kind of forceful
reason means by the means of reason or
the means of our own efforts we cannot
miss it we cannot reach the highest
patterns we cannot reach that which is
beyond all patterns another thing which
makes this pattern very powerful this
image very powerful is that there seems
to be an analogy we could kind of
understand it as an analogy at a lower
level between this image of the chariot
with the four Griffins and even the
divine chariot which has four cherubim
some people have suggested that even the
word Griffin and the word cherubim are
actually cognates that they that they
have some long distant source which is
the same and you can see it in the image
which is the cherub as as this kind of
hybrid figure that has different
different heads of different animals or
different body parts of different
animals depending on the description we
find in Scripture that this description
of the cherub is similar to a sphinx or
to a Griffin and that the Griffin can be
seen as analogous to that so for example
in churches some Byzantine churches
would have Griffin's on the outside of
churches and then you could still see
cherubs on the inside of the church
let's say on the veil or on different
aspects of the church you know either on
the different Church cloths or the
different icons so you can kind of see
it in different levels that you know you
can imagine the Griffin as being this
guardian but on the outside something
like a guardian in the sense of a king
or of an army and then
the inner Guardian who is the guardian
of the secrets of the mysteries the
spiritual guardian which is on the
inside and which is guarding the the
mysteries from profanation and so
there's an analogy and in the analogy of
course there is also like I said also
the separation which is that although we
can see the analogy between Alexander
going up into the sky and seeing the
patterns this is obviously at a lower
level than the actual divine chariot
which took Elijah and brought him up all
the way into the highest heavens one is
through the effort of man to raise
himself up and one is on let's say a
moving from above to bring Elijah up
into the highest heavens but there is
still an analogy between the two and so
what it does is it it gives what I like
about that story is that it gives value
to human capacity it gives value to
human effort but in the context of the
Christian version it also shows the
limit of human value and of human
capacity you know and the this legend of
Alexander became very famous in the
Middle Ages you can see it all over the
place from Byzantine ornaments you can
see it on buildings you see it at in
Venice on on st. mark Cathedral you also
see it in churches all the way to
England and you can see it in ornaments
all the way in in Persia and so you you
can see it as this celebration of human
capacity and also the value of the city
the value of the Roman Empire or the
vision of the human capacity to right
raise itself up and to become something
which is coherent but it also gives you
the limit it also shows you that you if
you go too high then you risk what
happened at the Tower of Babel is that
you risk the breakdown and if we look at
the modern world today what we can see
as we notice the fragmentation in the
edges as we see our own as we see
Western cultures start to be brittle and
start to break apart with we can surmise
from that is of course the very fact
that that modern thinking
and that the modern approach thought
that he could gather everything into
itself and thought that he could reach
the highest that he could either see it
as reaching God or getting rid of God so
that he could encapsulate the entire
world well in the story of Alexander we
see how we don't have to go into
extremes we can both celebrate the
capacity that humans have to participate
in the patterns and to see the patterns
but we also have to know that there is a
limit to which we can access them but
even for myself it acts as a warning not
to fall into hubris and not to think
that my own mind is going to be able to
master everything that I'm going to be
able to understand everything because
obviously that is sometimes a secret
temptation that we have that we think
all right I've reached it like I figured
it out but an image like that for me at
least is both a celebration and the
warning that I need in order to kind of
advance into this world of understanding
symbolism and so because the tale of
Alexander also has in it an aspect of
hubris at the same time it also has a
let's say something which precedes what
Christianity would become it has a a
kind of glimmer of what the possibility
of Christianity could be there is also
something in the story of Alexander that
is a warning and so you have different
commentators in the story of
Christianity which will warn us that the
figure of Antichrist is related to the
figure of Alexander and we see this in
the figure of Julian the apostate for
example and Julian the apostate is a
Christian Emperor who during his life at
some point switched he was raised as a
Christian and then he switched this is R
at the early stages of with the
Christian develop in the Christian
Church he switched and reverted back to
paganism and his form of paganism was a
kind of a strange fake paganism it kind
of pluralism where he was saying that he
wanted to you know open it up for all
different faiths he also said that he
wanted to rebuild the Temple in
Jerusalem he he did all these moves of
kind of open
culture to all kinds of things but
secretly it was driven it seems by an
animosity towards his own Christian
upbringing and his own Christian way of
seeing and he saw Julian he saw himself
as a new Alexander and so we have to be
able to hold a figure of Alexander in
these two on these two sides we need to
not be afraid of it because it has very
powerful storytelling in it but we also
have to see it as a warning in different
ways in the story itself as a warning
not to go up too high in the Christian
versions of the legend but the figure
himself as a warning of the danger of a
kind of all-encompassing Empire that
would encompass the entire world and
would want to would want to destroy the
particular story by giving access to all
these different stories at the same time
so it's something that hopefully the the
image of Alexander going up on his
Griffin's is something that will be a
source of meditation for you and I hope
to get back to the story of Alexander to
go into other versions other aspects of
it maybe in the comments tell me if
that's something that interests you if
you know some of the story of Alexander
maybe tell me which aspect of his story
you would like me to interpret because
it's such a such a big tapestry of
storytelling and so thanks everybody and
I will see you soon so hope you enjoyed
this discussion on Alexander the Great
if you announcement next week I will be
in Saskatoon giving a carving workshop
which is already full but if you are in
the area you can come to see a talk that
I will be giving it's a Saturday January
18th at 7 p.m. at Our Lady of Lourdes of
Lourdes Catholic Church in Saskatoon so
check that out I will also be in Boston
on February the 15th I will be giving a
talk at the Greek Cathedral the Greek
Orthodox Cathedral there it's going to
be two talks plus question period and
also a tour of the Cathedral all of that
for $15 which includes line
so that'll be February the 15th I will
put links to those events to the
Facebook events and also to the
Eventbrite site where you need to go to
get the tickets of the Boston event I'll
put all that in the description for
those who wish to come and of course I
hope to meet some of you there